foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream it's number 160 isn't it
it's number 160. is that Prime uh that
is not prime for at least one reason
um I asked our I asked our producer our
son Zach this morning if it was if it
was Prime and he said not for like a
million reasons and then we started
trying to figure out exactly how many
reasons there are that it's not prime
yeah it's it's either one or a small
handfuls but uh it's it's a handful it's
more than a handful yeah as is he
all right um I am Dr Brett Weinstein you
are Dr Heather hiing and uh yes we are
we are uh we are the doctor no we are
the dark horses in Residence of this
podcast
and uh yeah and today we're going to
talk just a little bit about the moon
we're going to talk about
um categories sex categories in things
like sports and uh Awards and awards for
things and we're going to talk about how
to not let what has happened over the
last three years or depending on the
framing 10 years 20 years 30 years
happen again and so we're going to
finish with that we might actually
finish with dogs but we're gonna I'm not
finished with dogs no no no for all
they're uncookedness indeed actually
we're gonna lead with this we're gonna
lead with dogs leading dogs that's a
natural yeah we're gonna we're gonna
leave the dogs our people have been
doing that for 30 000 years right right
exactly but
first some logistics for top of the hour
you can now follow Dark Horse Instagram
Facebook LinkedIn and Twitter we follow
these live streams with live Q and A you
can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com we encourage you
to pick up our book hunter-gatherers
Guide to the 21st century coming to many
more languages soon
and we have
um
our store has
darkhorsestore.org has great products
including
epic Tabby epic Tabby tote bag I thought
about putting the Epic Tabby in the tote
bag because like some cats he actually
enjoys doing that sort of thing but I
didn't have my uh my act together enough
very hard to fold the sheets after you
have laundered them because the cat
likes to get in the sheets and be and be
rolled around and agitated yeah see he
likes yes do not do not ever put your
cat in the dryer but if he likes to be
agitated consider putting in your sheets
yep yes
um
we find find me at Natural Selections uh
I wrote this week uh something I call
draw blue
and as always we want to thank you our
audience and we'll spend a little bit of
time
um exploring exploring who our audience
is later today but um we are very
grateful to you for subscribing for
sharing for liking uh when when you do
when you do like what you are hearing
from us and you can find us on YouTube
and odyssey our whole episodes and our
clips and of course uh the whole
episodes also go out to Spotify Apple
podcasts anywhere that you listen to uh
audio you had something to add no no
definitely never it's not my way oh is
that right is that right
and you can join one or both of our
patrons Brett had a conversation with a
small group of his patrons this morning
you will have another one tomorrow we uh
we do a private q a
um for patrons of mine on my patreon and
uh at at um and people on both of our
patreons can join our Discord server
where there's just a remarkable number
of really excellent people across all of
the demographic markers that you might
imagine uh having interesting
conversations in text audio video doing
karaoke doing all sorts of great stuff
so we encourage you to uh join up with
one of our patreons and find the Discord
server there and of course we have
sponsors top of the hour uh every every
week we have three sponsors who we have
vetted carefully and uh if we're if
we're reading scripts for sponsors it
means that we actually really do vouch
for vouch for these products and there's
lots that we uh reject because they're
just not right for us I believe it is
still true it is more than we have
accepted yeah that's right that's right
okay so without further Ado we've got
three ads for right at the top of the
hour here
House of macadamias
our first sponsor is this week is House
of macadamias which is nuts
tree nuts uh which includes
um most of the nuts you can think of
pecans walnuts cashews almonds
pistachios and more are delicious and
nutritious they are generally high in
fat and low on carbohydrates and they
are increasingly understood to be both
satiating and good for you
um instantly just I was thinking about
you know tree nut is a is a weird
category it's not a um biological
category it's it's more like a growth
habit than it is it's more like a growth
habit because you know peanuts are
legumes uh they're not and they do not
grow on trees but tree is a habit like
tree is not a single evolutionary thing
yeah right and so referring to something
as a tree nut is uh is a little bit uh
is a little bit of an odd category
anyway kicked a tree I pray yeah I think
I probably have a habit
oh terrible sorry apologies to all are
you though are you sorry a little house
of macadamias doesn't deserve this uh we
don't know that no no I haven't visited
do we have not yeah we haven't been
invited over no
um macadamias and tree nuts in general
um see previous aside are generally high
in fat and low in carbohydrates and that
is increasingly understood uh by people
who are thinking carefully about human
health as opposed to looking at a food
pyramid put out by people who didn't
know what they were doing back in the
70s uh high in fat loan carbs
increasingly understood to be both
satiating and good for you but each
species of nut is different of course
and for many of us macadamias are the
best macadamia nuts take a very long
time to grow longer than many of the
other nuts on that list I read and are
rare representing only about one percent
of nuts in the marketplace and because
they're both rare and
um and time consuming to grow and highly
sought after they have the dubious
distinction of being the world's most
expensive nut
but between the tastes and the health
benefits they're worth it they have
fewer carbohydrates than most other nuts
for instance half of what cashews or
pistachios have and two-thirds of what
almonds have which makes them a perfect
snack for breaking a daily fast and
controlling blood glucose they're also
uniquely rich in omega-7s including
especially palmitoleic acid and
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production fat loss and
heart health again with my footnotes
here I've got the I got the reference if
you guys want it and have some
the only podcast with footnotes in the
ads yeah now I found some good sources I
like these nuts are great but I also
went deep into the like and what is so
special about macadamia nuts in general
anyway deep into the weeds looking for
nuts I did I did and I found some House
of macadamias has great ones they are a
company obsessed with making this
amazing food accessible to everyone
they've partnered with more than 90
farmers in Africa and now make one of a
kind vegan keto and paleo snacks these
include their dark chocolate dipped
macadamias and delicious assortment of
bars made with 45 macadamia nuts
included salted caramel and chocolate
coconut our favorite product of theirs
are the Simply Delicious salted
macadamias made with the namibian sea
salt
they're amazing we love them and think
that you will too
our house of academias Highly recommends
House of macadamias for all of your
macadamic needs looking for something to
nourish and energize you while in
pursuit of the truth or the next Summit
go to www.house of macadamias that's
m-h-o-u-s-e-o-f-m-a-c-a-d-a-m-i-a-s.com
and use code Darkhorse for a 20 discount
on your first order
all right our second sponsor this week
is seed seed is a company focused on
bacteria and the microbiome and they
make a probiotic called dso1 daily
synbiotic with an N syn biotic I always
prefer eating real food to taking pills
say previous ad for Macadamia nuts but I
have to say I really love this product
if you've tried probiotics before and
they haven't worked or you've wondered
about them but haven't ventured in this
is a different kind of probiotic and
it's fantastic there are a lot of things
that you can do to enhance your health
our sign off here at Darkhorse is it
includes three of them be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside
but a lot is hidden in those words of
course what is good food for instance
good food is real food whole food food
has been alive recently and was grown
with care and conditions as ancient as
possible given the constraints of the
21st century but even many people who
eat such a diet are missing something
due to things like soil depletion and
the ways that pesticides and herbicides
travel even if uh even if you're buying
some eating food that was grown without
those things
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony
we need them this is why probiotics can
be an important tool in a healthy
lifestyle even if you eat nutrient-dense
food and avoid processed foods and sugar
but not all probiotics are created
equally
seeds dsl1 daily symbiotics a broad
spectrum true two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it contains 24 distinct
probiotic strains and they are in a two
in one capsule which protects the
probiotics until they hit the colon
where they are most effective if you've
taken a probiotic before and not felt
the difference it's likely because the
good bacteria weren't surviving your GI
tract seed is designed differently with
that two in one capsule and that's part
of why it works
since daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours and I use it daily at
this point
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 20 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Dark Horse at checkout all right I'm a
double dyslexic this morning with dirty
glasses and uh you know simple
processing problems so we'll see how
this goes okay our final sponsor this
week is mud water mud water is a coffee
alternative made with four medicinal
mushrooms plus herbs and spices with a
seventh the caffeine of a cup of coffee
you get energy without the anxiety
Jitters or crash of coffee it's
delicious if you like the routine of
making a drinking cup of warmth in the
morning but you don't drink coffee or
trying to cut down
try mud water it's February now did you
know that it was February now you
probably did yeah uh time for uh did you
not no I knew I knew I've known that
since the 2nd of February
um
that sounds about right right no it does
doesn't it um it's February now time for
you
to have realized what resolutions this
is not written correctly it is time for
you to have a Reckoning with whatever
resolutions you are still following
um and uh if you have abandoned
resolutions well there's always next
year I'm going to skip to the next
sentence if you're looking for a
different way to kick off your day a
delicious warming enhancing way that
isn't just a caffeine Rush try mud water
dude it's really great did I mention
that it's February all right each
ingredient was added with intention it
has cacao and chai lion's mane mushrooms
cordyceps chaga and Rishi turmeric and
cinnamon mud water also makes a
non-dairy creamer out of coconut milk
and MCT a sweetener out of coconut palm
sugar and lucuma the fruit of an Andean
tree used by the Inca in the subjugation
of their neighbors
um I don't know if they use Kuma to
subjugate their neighborhood no no they
use it in the subjugation of they used
it while subjugating
that's not in yes they used it near yeah
right now
I was aware of that yeah I don't know
that sweetener that mud water makes is
actually really good and I having spent
some time in the Andes as you have right
I had never heard of lakuma before you
went to the Andes and resisted the urge
to subjugate anyone so I appreciate that
yeah thank you you're welcome thank you
something or you can mix and match that
is the uh creamer and the
um
the sweetener and the chocolate in
February they all go great together
all right
um mix and match with actual cream from
a cow and their lucuma sweetener or
honey and their their creamer substitute
if you don't do dairy any number of
things yep can all be mixed and matched
this is the worst dad
ever
yeah but the thing is the product is
actually really really good all of them
are the both the mud water itself and
the lacuma-based sweetener and the um
the camera it's like MCT and coconut oil
based uh creamer it's really good are
you okay
oh okay you want me to finish yeah
February
oh wow it's March already
if you don't okay or you can mix and
match
add a bit of their coconut milk and MCT
creamer with some honey from your
favorite bees
if you don't have favorite bees get some
honey from your favorite beekeeper or
use mud Waters lucuma and coconut palm
sugar sweetener and skip the bees
entirely
mud water's flavor flavor
it's not going well
great man
water's flavor is warm and spicy where
they have chocolate plus Masala chai
which includes Ginger and cardamom
nutmeg and cloves you can drink it any
time of year including in February it's
also delicious blend it into a smoothie
try it with banana and Ice milk or milk
like substance mint cacao nibs and add
some of your favorite bees
right mud water is 100 USDA organic
non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher
certified and allows you to build a
morning ritual that promotes sustained
energy without the crash that is not
what's going on here instead it's not
caused this sort of thing
this morning we actually both had coffee
maybe that's the problem that could be
the problem visit mudwater.com Dark
Horse to support the show and use code
Darkhorse mud that's Dark Dark Horse Mud
I think you can spell all three of those
words at checkout for 15 off that's
m-u-d-w-tr.com Dark Horse use Dark Horse
Mud at checkout for 15 off in February
or in January if you can go backwards in
time in March they may have a different
offer but uh try it then too yeah all
right well that's it
um Goliath is having a terrible time
getting rid of us but the giggles might
do it that was one of those things I
fear it
yeah so you were saying February uh that
was you oh yeah all right yeah that was
all that okay so
full moon is imminent
yes those of you who live in a place
where you can see and
um and don't have to work that hard to
see it will recognize it has been waxing
now for you know close to two weeks
um and maybe you didn't notice you know
two weeks ago because uh like I think
we've I think we've said this before but
like the solstices and the equinoxes at
the solstices uh the day length is
relatively stable even though there is a
day at which uh you know it is a day in
the northern hemisphere in June 21st ish
uh where the sun is above the Horizon
for the longest moment of the year and a
day either side of it it's shorter but
it the change the change is slow and the
change is slow at the winter solstice as
well whereas it's really fast The
Equinox like we're getting into the time
of year now
um closing like getting to a point where
the rate of change is happening faster
and the in the moon phases uh feel very
similar that at new and full they they
kind of they kind of stick there's no
moon at all for some days and there's a
really very very close to full moon for
uh four or five days um so anyway we're
the official full moon is tomorrow
February 5th
um but it is so close to full now that
it is it is it is there and that's
interesting that raises a point though
because
you correct me if I've got this wrong
but the rate at which the
is the line at which the dawn or dusk
line on the moon must move at a
perfectly regular or near perfectly
regular rate around the Moon
it won't be perfectly regular because
the orbit of the moon isn't perfectly
circular but it ought to move at a
consistent rate but our Vantage Point
here makes it look like it is moving
slower as it approaches full or new
right
oh boy
um well but it's also it's but it our
view of it is not just about us and the
moon it's also about us it's also about
the sun relative the sun's position
relatively oh I think that's actually
going to be a very tiny contributor here
I agree it as a contributor
um but and actually that predicts it
ought to be
um different in the spring and the fall
but I guess my point would be if you
were to count
the number of miles per Earth day that
the
um
position of the transition from light to
dark on the moon moves it should be
about the same each day but the point is
when you are looking Edge on that motion
across a fixed number of miles on the
surface of the Moon looks like it is not
very much change at all because we're
looking at an angle I'm not sure this is
this is the explanation and here I am
using
data from others which is to say a moon
app
and the the moon app that that I like
shows the percentage of fullness of the
Moon each day and where while it is at
100 tomorrow is it something like 99.7
today and the day after it's at 100 it's
again above 99 right and you know it's
only a 28 day cycle entirely so it's
only a 14 day cycle to get from
completely full to completely not full
and it's it's incrementally
a much tinier change near full and new
near New right but that is from our
perspective yeah and so I think actually
it's going to be almost perfectly
regular and it's if you were to look
down on the moon for example then you
would see it it is a perfectly regular
or an almost perfectly regular cycle
around the Moon it is only around the
Moon
if you were looking down
um and you were looking at uh so you've
got half the Moon is lit
and the degree to which that swings
across the moon and thereby changes our
perspective that rate is constant but it
looks to us like it's not constant
because a swing of that fixed amount
when you're looking it's at the edge of
the moon is not going very far from your
perspective from your two-dimensional
perspective it's the two-dimensional
transition that that causes that I think
maybe I'm I am not I'm not convinced of
this because I I'm having I did not plan
I did not model out in my head the the
you know the three bodies and also the
different elliptical orbits of both the
moon around the earth it being tidally
locked
um also will change what we see like
like it's not also like we're always
seeing exactly yeah right
um but that so tidally locked means that
it's it's day around the earth is the
same thing as its year it's its actual
day is the same thing as it's year if we
count the year as one full rotation
around the area around the earth and I
don't know the different ellipses and
where they are relative to one another
of of the earth serpent around the Sun
or the moons or around the earth so
there's too many there's too many
variables here for me to be certain that
um that explanation is right I think it
yeah I don't know well people seem to
find every single thing we get wrong
plus a bunch of stuff that we didn't
actually get wrong so we are liable to
get feedback that will tell us one way
or the other
well I don't know but I just I'm not
sure there's a one way or the other here
I think it's I think even if what you
said is true it's not going to be the
only thing that's that's uh that that is
contributing to uh how it is that we
well I agree there's a slight difference
because uh
I can't quite do it but um yeah sorry
I've disrupted your flow yeah um I mean
we were just I just wanted to talk a
little bit about how you tell time on
the moon
which is actually um kind of deep in the
weeds and I'm not maybe we just
shouldn't do it at all now because I
feel like this is this is this has
gotten already Way Beyond I don't know I
want to know how to tell time but we
don't know that's that's the point is
um and I'm not you know let's let's I
think we should probably skip this
um maybe you can do we have are we ready
to go into the story that you want to
talk about okay
um
well I have something if you let's do um
yeah go for it so
um
an odd story that I don't want to focus
on led me to something that I think we
ought to talk a little bit about
um the odd story is somebody erroneously
accused me of plagiarism uh on the
internet they tried to coin a hashtag
and then it turned out that I had in
fact said the thing that they claimed I
had copied from them before they ever
said it so not only did I not get it
from them but um the order was reversed
it was an unwitting plagiarist claiming
that you had plagiarize them I think it
was a canonical the phrase was uh I had
said that the Omicron virus had appeared
to be Frozen in Time
and the person uh concluded that I must
have gotten that from them they had
another piece of evidence which also
doesn't establish this but it turned out
I had said it online before they had
before the point at which they pointed
out but it doesn't really matter that's
it's secondary to the the important
consideration here
the person in question
I don't have any reason to believe that
they are
a white nationalist or anything like
this but they do seem to have some
followers of this nature which I
discovered because in interacting with
their claim that I had engaged in
plagiarism these people showed up and my
being Jewish was important to them oh
good so anyway it's always fun that was
disturbing yes but then the really
disturbing thing happened something
about my having interacted with those
people online kicked me over into Nazi
Twitter
something that I did not know existed
some algorithm starts showing you Nazi
tweets yeah and I ain't talking about
white nationalist stuff I'm not talking
about race realism right those things
are bad enough I'm talking about actual
Nazi Twitter I'm talking about
awning videos of the fuhrer making nice
with children that have been put
together with soaring wistful music
really didn't know it was on there
shocked to discover it yeah so anyway on
the one hand the my point would be oh
Nazi Twitter exists real Nazi Twitter
real Holocaust denying
your loving Twitter is a real thing but
the more important thing I thought even
beyond that shocking discovery
was that it exists and the way Twitter
functions
I was completely unaware of it yeah
wasn't surprised they were white
nationalists but I was surprised to see
the depth of this and so I do think it
raises
there are several things that have
worked this way right so Elon did a
bunch of work to get rid of
um pedophile Twitter I don't exactly
know where that stands because pedophile
Twitter isn't something I was aware of
until that uh
fewer erupted a fewer is a bad term in
this discussion but it's spelled
differently oh good I'm rarely thankful
for such things but in this case I am
and I think really it's pronounced you
know yeah differently as well so fewer
versus furor yeah yeah but anyway okay I
wasn't really very she had a different
word entirely wow yeah yes
um but okay so there there the point is
there are aspects of Twitter that would
cause a normal person to absolutely
shudder in horror and these things it's
as if you know you are riding on the bus
with
um you know murderous Thugs who you
don't know are there and they're you
know making eye contact maybe they're
smiling at you as they're you know
plotting whatever it is they're plotting
and I'm not making an argument here for
what should be true
I don't know what should be true but I
am making an argument that it is vitally
important that to the extent that
um these uh communities
arise and live in our midst it's kind of
important that we know that they're
there this is true yep
this this
is absolutely true yeah
um is that that we got yeah I mean
that's so
um we were going to talk about different
award categories
um by Sexes uh if our producer is trying
to get my attention yes whatever okay
um
it's just not going well today I don't
know what we're trying to do
um should we talk about this or do we
want to talk about what he's doing okay
um
so
this and you can unfortunately we're in
Twitter again Zach you can show this for
a moment my screen uh this is actually
from a few weeks ago uh this is a tweet
about a guardian article I look forward
to a time where award shows can be
reflective of the society we live in is
a quote from the guardian article that
Sam Smith saying that at the Brits in
2021 wish granted question mark this
year our sexist society is reflected so
brilliantly that no women are nominated
for best artist Bravo genderists okay if
I may have my screen back for a moment
Zach uh
the uh actually no I'll just I'll hold
on to my screen so the the article that
the guardian
um has written then has this quote the
awards ceremony this is I don't remember
what it's called it's not in the
sentence on this paragraph the award
ceremony run by the British photographic
industry BPI did away with the best
British male and best female Awards in
2022 following criticism that the
non-binary pop star Sam Smith would not
be eligible for either prize despite
their massive commercial success
and uh apparently for uh two years
running now
um one of the downstream effects of that
has been there have been no women among
the finalists in a number of of
categories and so there's concern
obviously that out of deference to the
new fiction which it is of non-binary
which like you know go for it abandon
your gendered Norms but you're still
male or female so this new fiction of
non-binary is a meaningful descriptor of
identity
um is replacing male and female which
are biological realities people
um women will once again get less
recognition for their work right
um as NBS as the non-binary people
sometimes like to be called begin to
take spots that would have been spots
that women are getting so I I see this
as a concern I do I do see uh the the
the people who think that gender is more
important than sex and are making up
categories uh and obliterating reality
as very very much so
um basically coming in and taking some
of the many hard one rights of women
that is absolutely true but this
prompted me to think more actually about
categories of sex in the first place
across invariant various domains so in
sport we have a male and female category
and yes obviously actually and there's
still a lot of people fighting this
fight and you know I'm in that fight
sometimes and somehow this isn't totally
obvious to everyone but if
really unless you were born yesterday
this should be obvious right there's a
reason there are
different categories for men and women
in sport no amount of hormone disruption
blocking enhancement of cross-sex
hormone surgery kind of race Elite male
Advantage if you went through puberty as
a male right so that's that's one thing
at least in competitions of physical
prowess and strength right so and you
know that doesn't mean that you can't
have
um co-ed Sports and I've I've written
about and we've talked about for
instance how much we both loved and we
sometimes played competitively uh co-ed
ultimate Ultimate Frisbee and of course
there's mixed doubles in tennis you know
there are co-ed Sports where this where
they can make sense but it has to be an
explicit expectation right
so okay so sport different categories
for male and female in sport yes well
I want to pause you because the question
is
I do I am obviously a uh an advocate for
the same thing that such a category
should exist but the question is really
um
why do we do that okay but I'm getting
there okay okay
so different categories in sport yes
male and female
different categories in acting
doctor and actress
I think so for different reasons right
uh which is that male and female are
fundamental realities of humanity and
indeed of all vertebrates with a couple
of weird little exceptions where it's
still male and female are realities and
just a few species have ditched the
males and are all female now but they're
still female right
um but for humans male and female are
realities and have has been for the
hundreds of millions of years of our
lineage that we've had we've been
reproducing sexually and maybe again
that's closer to two billion
and some roles some acting roles may not
be sexed and those are some of the most
interesting roles honestly right like oh
that that story could be embodied by a
man or embodied by a woman but who is
embodying some story some character or
some narrative Arc
um does then somewhat change you know
how that story plays out and how that
character develops and what the risks
are and the realities and the history
and you know all of these things right
so
um
there are different ways of manifesting
in the world even though you can have
very sort of male like female approaches
to the world and very female-like
approaches to the world that are in the
opposite sex bodies of which they are
but in general I would say that
categories by sex for acting make sense
but
how about sculptors
no right like even even though even
though you may have on average a
different approach to sculpting based on
your maleness or your females femaleness
how about for screenwriters well no and
we don't right we don't have different
categories for male and female
screenwriters or for sculptors how about
Nobel prizes no right so why music
is music more like acting or is it more
like screenwriting right and I think I
can see an argument kind of
um
for both
um if it's an historic artifact then
it's kind of affirmative action for
women in music right if it's an
historical artifact in which it's a
recognition that uh female musicians
didn't really have an ability to get
recognized to get seen and so we're
going to create in a word category uh to
help to help women get seen well that's
different from it was necessary that men
and women had different categories for
music awards because male and female
music is different and so that brings me
to exactly what what you were you're
gonna jump the gun here on which is that
there are at least two reasons two
distinct reasons to have categories by
sex and I think there's actually a third
but the two main ones that are that are
detailed in the sort of list of like you
know yes for sports yes for acting no
for sculpting no for Nobel prizes no for
screenwriting music is a questionable
one one of the reasons to have different
categories by sex because men and women
are different and their skills and
talents manifest differently in the
world and so they're judged on different
scales or variables that's and you know
and yes the different ways that men and
female that men and females
males and females men and women manifest
in the world is a distribution rather
than a binary right like male and female
are binary and the ways that maleness
and femaleness manifests in the world
are
um you know more or less you know finite
normal distributions in terms of of of
how it is that that we show up in the
world
um but
it's about physical and biological and
frankly sort of population level
statistical reality and then the second
reason to have categories is again to
like fix an historical wrong to uh to to
recognize that women have been
historically underrepresented or
discriminated against and the categories
serve to write historical uh inequality
and a if that's the case for a
particular thing uh as as women reach
parity or it's clear that in some
particular field it's not going to
happen for reasons having nothing to do
with bias those categories should be
disappeared and they certainly shouldn't
be clung to because it's always the way
we've done it if they were about fixing
an historic uh wrong as opposed to about
recognition of an underlying reality
that isn't going to change no matter how
many people walk around saying that
they're pansexual envies or whatever it
is that they're claiming so let's unpack
a couple of those yeah
and I want to add an example
that I'm frankly not even sure how it
works but uh Billiards competitive
Billiards they're men's and women's
Billiards or do men and women compete on
the same playing field in Billiards I do
not know the answer to that my guess
would be same same playing field but I
don't know yeah that would be my guess
too but I'm not 100 sure I'm not even 60
sure of that uh Billiards competitions
male versus female something like that
um and I also want to add a an odd
exception maybe it's one of several but
American football
right there is no women's American
football right
um there's men's and women's soccer
interestingly I would guess rugby is
like football and that there's no
women's rugby no no there's
college level women's rugby I think but
anyway it is interesting that well and
then you have uh baseball and softball
right like women's baseball I mean
certainly some women play baseball
sometimes but I don't think that there's
professional women's baseball if you're
playing that kind of a game as a woman
professionally you're playing softball
and Men also play softball right but
women don't also play baseball I think
right now I can't I don't think I ever
saw A League of Their Own but am I right
that women were playing baseball during
the War I thought it was softball but I
remember well in any case there's an
interesting landscape here why don't we
have women's football uh why you know
why is the logic of soccer not the same
logic as American football
um there's a question about whether or
not
so
if men play at a higher level in uh
sports that are physically that physical
prowesses the question
um then it's interesting that women's
sports work and I want to point out why
I think they do but
if you what do you mean what they work
what does work mean if
the top men
are
if no woman can compete with the top men
in a sport like let's say tennis
then the question is why if people are
going to see the top tennis players does
women's tennis make sense and the answer
so you're talking about as a spectator
sport that is a sport as a sport there's
I don't think oh right right question
right no I I am talking talking about
the spectation yes I'm talking about why
it makes sense that we have you know
amends and women's division at Wimbledon
for example
um and I think the answer is not a word
incidentally what that's the word I used
expectation expectations I like it
um well you can be very persuacious so
um precisely yeah the so I guess my
point would be one of the things about
you know what is a sport
a sport is a a physical game in which
the obstacles faced by the competing
parties are the same right so they you
know you can't play soccer on a slanted
field
um or if you do then the point is each
side spends if you play soccer in a
v-shaped field in which the goals are at
the end
yeah a little bit like ulama the uh the
Central American ball game but oh yeah
yeah with the slanted size but anyway
put that aside for a second
the game neutralizes now extinct
um like Aztec I think or Toltec or
something I believe it was actually
passed down the Olmec the Toltec the
Aztecs all played ulama and ulama still
exists it's just such a hard game that
it's not when it's played now though it
doesn't end in human sacrifice or no not
of either the winners or the losers
which I understand different cultures
did it differently yeah but this is a
game in which uh there's a tiny little
hoop like a basketball hoop but it's up
on edge and the ball I think can only be
uh passed around and launched with the
hip
it's a very crazy game but um
but anyway point is top women competing
with each other is not inherently a much
worse game than the top men pitted
against each other because they're even
with each other and and so anyway the
point interested in physical skill and
prowess if you're only interested in you
know speed and force yeah then uh the
the women's sport is not going to give
you as much of that as watching men's
sport but in general sport is not just
about
um you know sheer you know speed and
force right it's about skill and and
frankly and this is you know as I've as
I have said before back when we were
playing a lot of ultimate I played um I
played on the University of Michigan
Women's team uh for for a bit and then
we played a lot of summer summer league
and you know captained co-ed teams and
um and also went to some you know
day-long tournaments and such and
watched
um and so watched a lot of men's games
played in this certain number of women's
games and played way way way more
co-ed games and and and and Captain
co-ed teams and by far for me now
obviously I never played on a men's
men's game but by far the most
interesting of those was was the co-ed
games
um because men left their own devices on
the field we're much more likely to just
like hook it long one guy runs down you
know maybe he gets to lay out and you
know it's it's awesome for those two
guys and it's pretty great for the other
you know depending if it's a full you
know thing the other five people five
it's been a while seven yeah right seven
people don't recall oh goodness it's
been that long yeah um
the other people on the team but the
points are short and
um it's you know to you know to the
Victor go the spoil sort of thing and
um by contrast the women the women's
only uh games are much more likely to
involve very short passes much more
cautious less risky short passes it
takes forever to go down the field
um the person who does want to hook it
long or run and run and you know dive
into the end zone is much less likely to
have the opportunity and uh and there's
also more much more of a focus and this
will come as a surprise to No One
probably in our audience even if you
have no idea what ultimate frisbee is uh
is that on women's only in women's only
games and on women's only teams there's
much more of a focus on like let's make
sure everyone gets to handle the disc
like and let's let's make sure that
everyone ends up getting to play like
actually this is competition here that's
that's not supposed to be one of the
main things and so you have these like
you know these slightly too much like
almost caricatures of maleness and
femaleness in an all-male Game of
Ultimate and all female game ultimate
and because this is not supposed to be a
contact sport uh and it really does work
as a co-ed in a co-ed game and usually
you know five two five men two women
four men three women something like that
and you got to be you know matched up
pretty well
um you actually reduce some of the
silliness of the extreme all male and
all female exigency is when you're
playing together right and it's
fantastic but it is neutralized
structurally as part of the game
ultimate is a strange game because it
actually builds into the structure of
the game uh inclusiveness and fairness
they're like the game actually has the
rules written in that somebody doesn't
understand a rule of placed stops and
the rules explain and all that so anyway
the point is structurally
in Ultimate right you wouldn't pick
teams and have an uneven number uh you
wouldn't have you know the preponderance
of of women on one team uh that would be
an unfair game there is a tendency to
balance the number of women on each side
and there is a tendency for players not
necessarily by sex but players to match
up with a player of similar skill and
speed so that one person is not fully
shutting down the other person so the
point is the game and if you don't have
that then you do a different kind of
Defense you don't do a man on defense
you do his own defense or something
because if you don't really have roughly
you know this is more in a non you know
strictly competitive situation right uh
like okay are we are we out here are we
doing pickup to have fun or to brutalize
the other team and the other team we're
going to swap it up in 15 minutes and
some of you people who I was just trying
to brutalize are going to be on my team
like yes I'm on a team right now and I
want to win this point because that's
fun and that's kind of why I'm out here
but I'm also not interested in like oh
let's line up with you who I know I can
take an outrun and then the point's
going to be over really fast yeah it's
not interesting not interesting yeah
um so
well anyway look I think I think the the
really interesting one here is the
acting one and your question is a great
one about why the acting before we go
back to acting though because I actually
um you kind of predicted one of the
other places I wanted to go and maybe
we'll end end on acting I actually found
um in the Seattle Times uh a couple
weeks ago January 22nd there's an
article called the headlined renowned
Hawaii surf contest the Eddie plans
return after seven years and I don't I
don't surf
um I've I've never watched a surfing
contest I don't know very much about it
despite having grown up in Los Angeles
um but one of the things that they say
in here in this article and I have
failed to Mark where it is is that for
the first time I believe
um ever they're inviting women to
compete
so this is this is not going to be the
Eddie and maybe this has already
happened at this point I think this has
been long enough
um uh for the first time it's not going
to be just a male only competition and I
thought okay
so we have as the reasons that I had
come up with for why there need to be
categories by under what conditions
there should be categories by sex
um in those situations where men and
women are just fundamentally different
enough that
um combining
um you know combining the sex categories
would mean that women wouldn't get to
play basically
um there is the historical reason for
like oh we're gonna write some wrong and
so make sure that uh you know women get
um get get voice here and then there's
um
this is about human versus nature and so
I you know I looked into how it is a
surfing contests are judged and it's a
little it's a little figure skating-y
right so there's a lot like it's judges
on the top and the bottom scores are
mostly dropped and I'm sure it's
different and different in in different
competitions but
um they're assessing on a number of
things like how many Maneuvers they use
and and you know and how you know
obviously if they
if they wipe out that's not good
um but there are measures of like you
know apparent power apparent strength
apparent fluidity on on the wave which
is going to give an advantage to to male
Surfers but if a competition is on a
particular day at a particular break and
apologies I'm probably not using exactly
the right words here but you know there
will be different waves that happen at
10 A.M versus
2PM of course but if it's your turn to
go out part of what you're being
assessed on is like which wave did you
choose and the waves are the waves uh
then it's you know it's human against
nature which is
um remarkable and in this case like well
um you know men may have a little bit of
an advantage but really like what are
you going to do if you're going to make
if you're going to call surfing a sport
and this gets back to the question like
what is a sport if you're going to call
surfing a sport just like if you're
going to call figure skating a sport
you're going to have to introduce some
social means by which you're assessing
whereas if it's a you know it's llama in
mesoamerica or Ultimate Frisbee or
American football or you know what
everyone else calls footballers the
world soccer uh where there are you know
formal rules it's you know there is you
know there there are there are
dimensions and specificities around the
court or you know or the field and the
size or shape density of the ball or the
disc or whatever it is and how it is
that you score and what the conditions
are then you can control everything and
it's it's a little bit like human versus
nature but controlled it's like we've
domesticated yeah it's a domesticated
War at some level and then like okay now
let's now let's play at this it's a
laboratory sport in the sense that the
laboratory purges all of the extraneous
uh influences as much as possible so
that you can see the effect and a tennis
court is similar to this whereas you
know it's like the difference between
um uh gymnastics in the Olympic sense
and parkour which makes use of exactly
things that are non-standard
um but I did want to uh you want to go
back to acting well before that I wanted
to point out that there are two reasons
there are two male female asymmetries
that could result in the need for a
female category in sport one of them
might have to do with the fact that
males have an advantage because the
sport uh depends on strength and things
like that and my guess would be this is
somewhat relevant to
um surfing but you know there's a
question about if you scaled the board
down so that it was the same ratio of
person to board
maybe it's not on the other hand I don't
know
um on the other hand
to the extent that something is highly
competitive
it might be that if you didn't have
separate uh male and female categories
and you were looking at elite players
that women would not get there because a
much smaller pool of them would ever
have tried the sport and so the point is
the Tails of the distribution that show
up would be much smaller and so the
number of people who would be able to do
it at an elite level having nothing
inherent to do with their capacity just
having to do with the fact that the
competitive modality would tend to
census more widely amongst men well as
you know I don't I don't buy this line
that is very common in the psychological
and other literature that women artists
competitive as men I think it's it's
total crap yeah but I'm not but men and
women compete differently it manifests
differently so if you're reading
something into my point it's not there
because my point is in the athletic
modality you would have had fewer women
attempt this and so we'd find we
wouldn't find that many who have that
Elite capacity so I agree with you yes
women are equally additive and it's
different but the sporting modality
leans in the direction of men
yeah I think it would depend on depend
on the sport
um but that's interesting it's a
different selection
bias it's a it's a selection bias about
choice in advance
and this you know this is related to
some of the
some of the correctives that people are
trying to put into place not in sport
but in things like you know equity in
you know software Engineers you know the
sex ratio of software Engineers uh
whereas once you know Equity has been
achieved and actually like flown past
and now you have more women in say
medical school than men apparently I saw
I saw I saw this recently
um
no one no one is saying oh we like maybe
we should then maybe we should slow this
down if what we're seeking if what we
were seeking was equity which is to say
uh you know and I don't I don't think we
should be but if what we were seeking
was that then it's supposed to match the
sex ratio of the population then we got
a problem we do have a problem we got
you know we got two manure institutions
favoring
um sort of female style of learning and
and making their way through the world
such that increasingly
um a lot of really really great manner
like not for me that's doesn't this is
not doing anything for my brain I'm not
going to be able to manifest myself here
so I'm going to go do something else and
you know that's that's bad news and we
don't see we don't see that very much
being recognized we don't it's arguable
that it's correcting uh you know a
long-standing wrong and that's why they
don't respond I think it's nonsense but
uh but it's possible but let's go back
to the acting question I think it's
really where the rubber meets the road
here
in some sense
and you mentioned that there are
characters that aren't
sex specific I must say I'm struggling
to think of one
I've seen I've seen plays put on in
which a character that is traditionally
male is played by a female or something
no that's that's different that's that's
obviously sexed enough that it's playing
with gender expectations
um well okay so the first that came to
my mind is not great because I've I've
actually never seen the movie but uh how
about something like Forrest Gump
uh uh which character
Forrest Gump character
isn't it inherently a guy why why does
it have to be I mean it's it's it's a
character who is
um as I like again this is a weird
example to be choosing because I haven't
seen it
um but isn't it Tom Hanks playing
someone um maybe strongly autistic uh
and you know autism does manifest
differently typically in men and women
but
um you know sort of going through the
world without some of the editing
um that might keep keep this person from
interacting with other people in the way
that they might normally do I think
I think there are definitely
possibilities for people to you know
just like
Children characters you know
prepubescent children characters uh are
do are often not inherently sexed well I
think the four I I think I saw Forrest
Gump many years ago
um and I think it is a very it is a
sexed role in the sense that a lot of
the
uh stuff that takes place in the movie
is not interchangeable but anyway let's
put that part aside let's just say
um
there is something that I think we all
intuitively understand and then some
fraction of us are going to deny it
right because we're involved in a
political uh an ideological move but we
all understand that actually being male
and being female even if you are a uh a
female who has many male gender
attributes
still the rules are so different
that the question the reason that we
would have different categories with
acting awards for example is that
there's a question it's not a question
of how good an actor you are it's a
question of how well you act in a
particular role and because at the very
least it is true that we are struggling
to find examples where our role isn't
explicitly sexed
um the point is
best actress on Earth or the best
actress in a movie role in the last year
is a different question than the best
male actor because inherent to virtually
any role are things that uh you know my
guess is
the best
actress on Earth
will portray a wide range of female
characters
um wonderfully and struggle to plausibly
portray most male characters right
because the point is it the the thing
the court is different in some sense
yeah although this then feels like it's
skirting close to the I believe
nonsensical argument that if you aren't
the thing you can't play the thing oh no
no and so you know we certainly see this
over in like trans space right like oh
well you know we've got trans characters
you can't have a non-trans actor play
trans character well no
that's what acting is right right
um oh we have a Native American
character there it has to be a Native
American person playing
that role like well if what you're
saying is
to write an historical ROM of Native
American under representation in roles
in Hollywood than whenever you have a
Native American character you should
have a Native American playing it that
is one argument
that that is an argument that we can
talk about if the argument is as it is
generally
um stated it is you know it is
I don't even I don't even know how it
stated but it's it doesn't it doesn't go
there it's just like you can't you
cannot that I mean that's what it is
it's not even an argument it's an
authoritarian like you cannot have a
role uh of someone who's disabled played
by a non-disabled actor if someone who's
trans played by a non-trans actor
someone who's Native American played by
a non-native American actor and
you know actually what acting is is
being able is having such remarkable
theory of mind that they really can
inhabit someone else's being and if
hopefully it's written well enough the
character's written well enough that
they really can go into that and and be
it and you know the example that
everyone knows of like in Shakespeare's
time women weren't on the stage and so
Men played both the male and the female
actors that was presumably not because
you know it was it was more like oh it's
the slight guy who's like it's the it's
the it's the guy with the slight
physique who's going to play the woman
as opposed to the one who sort of has
more of a feminine nature but
I think there I and I'm not coming up
with examples at the moment but I think
that there have been compelling
renderings
um that make you think about what it
means to be feminine to be masculine not
to be male or female right right no I I
am of course not making that argument
and I would say that the um the
correction we can see because
um the idea that a woman can't write
a male character compelling is the
compellingly is insane right right right
women do this all the time men write
women characters may be less often
compellingly but it happens
um and so anyway it's not it's not a
theory of Mind issue it's a question of
how compellingly can you represent and
you know let's be honest this is sort of
the proof of what we've been saying you
can identify somebody's sex very
frequently by their gait you know at 100
meters right right occasionally you're
wrong but very very rarely and that's
the way they're moving their arms yeah
right and you know the voice it's an
octave off oh interesting right that is
an interesting fact that it's an octave
off so anyway the point is it makes
sense because these roles we can't help
it that's the thing is you you can be a
leftist activist as much as you want but
we cannot help but categorize this stuff
because we're built to because literally
millions of years of evolution has
driven to pick this up as one of the
first characteristics we identify
because everything that follows from
that is different depending on it yeah
and there are
there are
ways
around with gender roles and gender
norms and not deny reality and in fact
actually I wasn't going to say anything
about this but I was in Portland for a
few days this last week as you know
that's why I wasn't here
was that where you were I thought it was
because it wasn't February yet yes right
um and while there I saw
this fantastic piece of Live Theater
um called something like and I something
like Ms Holmes and Ms Watson or Miss I
don't remember Miz or Miss Miss Holmes
and Miss Watson and it's a modern day
reimagining of Sherlock Holmes and John
Watson yeah yeah
um as female characters in like 2021
and uh I must say uh in advance of the
play when they started doing the land
acknowledgments and the talk about all
the people that we have to make sure to
include and this that and the other it's
like oh god what have I gotten myself
into but the play itself was Exquisite
it was it was really excellent and
especially
um you know more more than more than the
writing actually we're in the
screenwriting but the four actors
involved three of whom uh were women one
of whom was was male were extraordinary
and none of them were doing caricatures
of one sex or the other uh they weren't
pretending that it's that it's nothing
to have Sherlock Holmes now be
um actually I think I think they kept
the name Sherlock I think it's still
Sherlock Holmes
um but as a woman and it just it worked
brilliantly and I thought oh here here
it is like here here is a case where it
can be done really really well and no
one is no one is being forced to say
actually
um yeah those clothes that the emperor
is wearing are really really nice like
no one would have to do that for the
show
so let's
I I'm
I confess I am not
uh able to quickly spot why music is
different it's clear that it is the
difference
from which uh the rule that I'm arguing
is pretty much a rule yeah acting male
and acting female are sufficiently
different that you know Joan of Arc
would not be well played by a man even
though she was a masculine woman right
um so anyway there's something about in
acting space there appears to be a very
significant
based in ancient stuff reason for that
sexual distinction that sexual
distinction existed in music and it has
broken down in our lifetime I think much
to our benefit
it is somehow a more flexible uh and
I've seen it break down in a couple ways
actually there are a lot more women
making compelling uh rock and roll or
some derivative of it right there's a
lot of good bands that either include
women you know the yeah yeah yes for
example metric or you know are female in
nature the bands themselves
um
and there's been a lot of exploring
they're pioneering in ways they're not
just sort of doing what the guys do yeah
um there's all and it's not the music
equivalent of like romance novels yeah
right exactly that's right no no pop
exists on both in both sexes and like
that's not what you're talking about
they're pushing the same they're pushing
the edges of the same envelope I would
say
um there is also a
flight change in what was effectively a
rule about sex and gender in music where
it was okay for a woman to sing a man's
set of lyrics but a man couldn't really
sing a woman's right that has broken
down there's some famous examples of men
singing a song that is clearly from a
woman's perspective and it working very
well like uh Jolene right the White
Stripes version of Jolene is one and
what's another there's oh The Lumineers
um there's a song uh
that's actually it's a fascinating song
written
um I think the lead singer was in a taxi
in Europe somewhere and uh
the taxi driver had
um he was driving a taxi had lost the
you know love of her life her timing was
bad and anyway she had kind of a tragic
story and so he wrote it as a song and
um anyway it's quite a good song but
again it's a guy singing uh as if he
were a woman and it works you know yeah
now I feel like um some of Bonnie writes
Bonnie Wright Bonnie Wright's music has
been covered by uh male singers that's
right uh I can't I can't think of
particular examples but yeah but yes so
that and that is that was a norm that ex
that you know I I think I never heard
anyone say this but I think it was
imagined that male singers embodying
female thoughts and voices was somehow
emasculating yeah and so this is this is
one of the wins this is one of the wins
of feminism and of 20th century
liberalism like you know what it doesn't
need to be that way no and if it's not
if that's not your thing that's cool
um but this actually can free the
creative mind
um to say you know what I've got to take
on that and I know I understand that
that is is written
um you know by and from and of a female
perspective but I have something to add
and I'm not going to pretend that this
is now the only way to do it right that
that's that's not the way to go
um but hey guess what there's there's
another way to do this
um right and it opens up so two examples
I've given of men singing uh lyrics
written from a woman's perspective they
portray it from a woman's perspective
and then there's the cake
rendition of uh
I Will Survive
which actually turns the song on its
head I'm not sure I know that
um oh it's it's wicked it's really good
um but anyway it takes on an entirely
different character
um you know you know in the original
version that's sort of this woman who's
um
been I don't know if it's a physically
abusive relationship but she's clearly
been an abusive relationship and she's
standing up for herself but you know
abuse Works differently depending upon
who's meeting it out if it's you know
the physically weaker sex the abuse is
of a very different nature and so all of
the lyrics Do I Will Survive become
something else anyway so they don't
change the lyrics right but they also
don't pretend that they're not male
singing it
correct and uh and it is it is a very
different very different song at that
point you know and of course the White
Stripes version of uh of Dolly Parton's
song is also quite different and
apparently there's a famous uh
correspondence between the two where
Dolly Parton is not
compelled by Jack White's version and
Jack White makes the argument that
actually he's he's staring at the deeper
meaning in the song well this is I mean
that that
is an argument that is unsexed right
like that that is a an old an abiding
argument in literature but I mean I
think maybe in any kind of creative
space but specifically in music and in
literature around like well maybe not
literature so much well playwrights
playwrights I created the thing and the
way that you have manifested it is it
you've missed my point and to which the
you know director and the producer and
the you know all of the and the actors
and you know everyone else involved in
the production can say you know what
you you put this thing out into the
world and you can have your
understanding of what that is but uh but
but you put it out into the world for us
to now do with what what we want with a
play it's this is an obvious argument to
be made right it's like well the play
doesn't have that much meaning like I I
happen to love theater enough that I
have a you know I have a shell of books
of of plays but really reading a play is
a very weak way in to what a
playwright's mind was trying to
accomplish and uh and music even even
more so that if you if you understand
yourself to be
um
well especially like a singer-songwriter
right uh you you if you're successful at
all probably some of your songs will get
taken and adapted and transformed and
understood differently and uh how
amazing that you have the potential to
uh to say you know what you got that
wrong and to have the other person say
you can say that you can believe that
and you do believe that but um I think
differently yeah and then there's a
third possibility which is the
um
teleportation of some sort of a
canonical idea into a new realm so you
know we keep
having to reinvent Plato's Cave because
Plato's Cave is so so uh archaic yeah um
but the Matrix is very Vivid to us Gen X
types right it has a deep a deep meaning
uh or um West Side Story and its
relationship to Romeo and Juliet but
there are things which need to be
um updated and the the point is how much
of the original you keep you know uh
Heart of Darkness and uh Apocalypse Now
right there's very little that's
maintained there's sort of a basic you
know descent into a place beyond the
metaphorical truth about at the Heart of
Heart of Darkness is there but I mean
it's even transformed the Heart of
Darkness is Africa yeah and Apocalypse
Now is Vietnam yep right uh so uh the
you know but you know but
but the uh
the white man explorer who loses his
mind and uh wreaks chaos and havoc and
destruction on a native population and
needs to be stopped by you know more
more later white explorers is
um
is the is the is one of the points of
connection between those two renderings
yeah yeah absolutely and then I'm
thinking of another version which I
can't remember the name of the second
movie but uh do you remember that there
is a movie
um
along the same plot as Dr Strangelove
actually released it approximately the
same time
I don't but it's a serious version
really only the Kubrick version lasts in
people's memory because you know it's so
so remarkably different from anything
else that had ever been made
um but there was another version that
had the same uh you know nuclear uh
nuclear narrative that has run away and
the bombs can't be recalled and
um anyway
it's a deadline I think uh I mean this
this
this is maybe part of the point to sort
of come full circle is that these
questions of adaptation
um you know the the particulars may be
sexed and you know some some
occasionally a an original female
Creator may feel that her work was not
honored appropriately was not taken
seriously enough and she may be right
because she was female right uh that
will more rarely happen in but for
original male creators right
um but barring those incidents which
must exist but um I would argue will be
a small fraction of um the cases where
there's disagreements about the quality
and the mode of the adaptation that it's
about it's about creativity and yes
creativity will maybe tend to manifest
somewhat differently in male brains and
hands and female brains and hands but
the question of no actually I had
something different in mind you didn't
get it no uh what was in your work that
you didn't know was there was this and
you know that's a that's a staggering
thing to be told as a Creator like you
you you think you found something that
in in what I did that I don't know was
there and that you're seeing my work
more clearly than I did
that you know that's that's its own
philosophical conundrum uh and has
nothing to do with male versus female
it's funny you know I don't I I can
imagine being affronted by such a thing
but in science it's so it's so much the
regular phenomenon and it's actually a
Hallmark of a kind of success right you
found an idea so deep you don't see to
the bottom of it right which is actually
one of the things I was trying to tell
Richard Dawkins about memes that he
doesn't get right he sees them as
trivial and parallel to genes and it's
like no no no you don't understand how
much of the magic that is the unique
status of humans is an evolutionary
phenomenon is the result of the fact
that the relationship between genes and
memes isn't the one you've spotted right
so I mean this this is fantastic science
and uh
more completely creative work because
science is very very creative of course
but
um our are different in this regard and
just like and and maybe this is a decent
segue to you know science and journalism
are not the same thing they don't follow
the same rules they don't follow the
same expectations and people in
journalism who say oh follow the science
and you know like you know who who think
that they know even though they
recognize that actually they're
enumerate and don't know what they're
talking about are making a tragic and
profound error by imagining that science
and journalism the same thing same thing
science and the law totally different
expectations you know in in basically
every regard and so yeah as you know for
me as both the scientist and someone who
is who is you know an active Creator in
you know non-scientific Creator space
uh I can I definitely feel the like oh
boy if I've if I've written a thing that
is just explicitly creative that is not
non-fiction
um
the idea of it being grabbed by someone
else and turned into uh you know
something a different medium uh would
feel like oh God you know can you ah
like what what are you gonna do to it
that thing was mine whereas with science
uh you know there are
ideas there are formulations that are
yours because you came up with them but
they don't belong to you they belong to
the universe right uh they you know you
have it is Discovery
it is Discovery rather than creation and
that is a fundamental difference and you
know what journalism is doing what
journalism and law are entirely human
constructs as is you know the human
creative process whereas science is
about Discovery and the humans
don't come first well so let's draw the
distinction the stuff
the
model that you happen onto is a feature
of the universe if your model is
accurate yeah the process by which you
come by it may be just you and frankly
you may not even know what it is because
you know as we have pointed out multiple
times you can tell a student oh you make
an observation about a pattern and then
you come up with a hypothesis what you
can't do is then explain oh here's how
you're going to come up with your
hypothesis right and coming up with the
hypothesis is the is the core of the
creative part of science that's what I'm
saying and it's not even something that
those of us who are good at it can
explain how we do it right because you
can't you can't nor can the sculptor
looking at the stone
described to a a mentee like this is
this is what you're going to do to find
the inspiration in the stone yeah and
you know there are bits and pieces and
you know and you could practice and you
can watch the the person learning and to
hypothesize of the person learning to
sculpt I say oh I wouldn't you know see
that there's that crack there and if you
do that it's likely to cause this
problem over here but you can't there is
is no recipe yeah there is no recipe the
only thing I can do with hypothesis is
show you how I come up with one and then
you can
see if you can find your way to
something that does the same job yeah
let's let's play let's let's now go
outside into the complexity
and and look around and wait for the
questions to occur excuse me and then
and then and then play around with the
ideas that show up and see like which of
these are hypotheses yeah oh some of
them aren't hypotheses because they're
un you know they're they're untestable
and in fact
um
one of the
pickles that we find ourselves in in the
present is that because the science is
no longer taking place in the University
right some yeah simulation of science is
taking place there but it's obviously
pretty feeble given what it's incapable
of doing
um
we are now doing this stuff in the open
which is kind of not the way it's
supposed to be and it means
that you know in order to come up with a
hypothesis you have to entertain a lot
of things that don't qualify right right
you have to you have to free yourself
enough that you're not constantly
shouting at yourself that that's an
irresponsible idea to traffic in right
so right um so anyway you play with
these ideas and then hopefully by the
time you get around to voicing it you've
edited down to something that you can
make some kind of Defense of
um but you know there's no defending the
thought process that comes up with a
viable hypothesis because it considered
40 that weren't viable you have to try
out everything possible yeah and anybody
who thinks that they're going to
micromanage you and keep you away from
bad ideas is also keeping you away from
usable ideas because you can't get to a
hypothesis without that license and
they've demonstrated that they don't do
science and they don't know what science
is yeah yeah it's that's about power or
at least at best it's about confusion
about a process that they are not able
to do yeah Power confusion censorship
one or all all of those yeah
So speaking of Butch
why don't you take over I've got some
things to add but uh sure so I wanted to
talk a little bit about something that I
actually encountered two different
versions of it in the last
week in a couple of days but I want to
explain why this is worth doing at all
um because I think it could easily be
misinterpreted so I want to talk a
little bit about an
um an interview or a discussion that
took place on Barry Weiss's podcast
honestly with a woman named Helen Lewis
and the problem is that that the two of
them uh
specifically take me to task and we will
come back to the meaning of that but I'm
not interested in talking about this
because they take me to task though it
does mean that I am expert on some of
the things they say and I am in a
position to comment on the veracity or
lack thereof of those things
but here's what I'm concerned about and
I think we've talked about this at least
once before
at the moment you have a scientific
establishment that has
to put it gently completely fumbled the
ball on covet
and
having fumbled the ball it has put a lot
of people in a very compromised position
people who aren't professionally
involved in science and some of them
aren't don't really have a deep
relationship with science at all they
trusted people who should be trustworthy
and it turned out those people are
terrible at what they represent
themselves at being excellent at
you and I are in an interesting
predicament because we have a
large number of places where we
challenged the official narrative and
now it turns out that we were correct
now as I said last week and I've said
many times before we did not start out
correct
what happened was we started with
educated guesses hypotheses and got
more and more correct over time as we
built up a model how do you do that by
monitoring how predictive it is a
phenomena in the real world so your
model gets better and better it gets
more and more predictive maybe it
assumes less and less right that's the
process we went through
the problem is that creates a challenge
to all sorts of powerful forces going
forward because if you and I actually
succeeded in doing that right in out
thinking the experts not by using
anything fancy without their advantages
without any inside information without
the ability to commission experiments or
any of the things you might do in order
to really be at The Cutting Edge if we
were able to do it just by talking it
out
then something is really wrong that
should not be possible Right
find out think a certain number of
departments a field every now and again
but it shouldn't be possible to just
beat them across the board
to the extent that it is possible yes
it's nice that you and I have those
capabilities yes we studied a topic
which puts us in a good position to do
it because it has a generalist toolkit
that comes along because evolution is
relevant to many of the sub questions
that are involved in this but it is also
evidence that something is desperately
wrong with the institutional world right
so my claim is
the institutional world has to find a an
excuse to
um
discount
what our viewers and listeners know
happened on Dark Horse it has to find
that now if it just had to find that and
it was alone in the universe fine it
would have a hard time
but it actually has a corresponding
group of people a large audience of
people who were taken in by the CDC by
the New York Times by all of the
official Outlets that were supposed to
be doing the work of curating the
information seeking new data right all
of the things that were supposed to work
to tell you what to think about covid
right the failure of that thing resulted
in a lot of people whose worst error was
just simply to trust that the experts
probably knew what the hell they were
talking about right those people got
burned
now some of them got injured
right some of them just got humiliated
and hopefully they haven't been injured
but the point is you've got a large
audience of people who got suckered by
something and are now trying to figure
out how to go back to living a normal
life and you've got a whole bunch of
people who screwed up who don't want to
be displaced over the fact that it is
now evident that they do not know what
they are doing and those two things are
now searching for a narrative in the
middle
and that narrative in the middle
is is kind of a negotiation right the
powerful people don't really want to be
Vindicated they can't be they got it
wrong what they want is to be slapped on
the wrist in a way that does not
threaten their position of power and the
people who got suckered would like to be
relieved of that sense of a oh there are
no experts that's a problem how am I to
live am I just going to wake up panicked
every morning right they would like to
be relieved of that they would like not
to feel
um so much like suckers they would like
to have somebody put into words the
mechanism by which they followed What
should have been true and reliable
instincts and ended up in danger right
and so my claim is that there is now a
struggle happening where
um influencers some of them humiliated
are now
seeking to
to provide a cell
where that sense of discomfort and the
powerful who do not want to be displaced
over their failure are interested in the
same thing and the Confluence of those
two things is a very powerful draw that
is going to pull people in if we're not
careful now
is it Petty to be focused on the fact
that this Viewpoint that they are
erecting is nonsense No in fact the
future depends on us not falling into
this trap and I will say at the
beginning of covid
what I said at least to those close to
me was that this was likely the best
opportunity that we were ever going to
get in our lifetime to reveal what was
taking place in the system the
dysfunction that you see inside of a
university right the failure of
Journalism to find obvious stories and
to report them these things are our
system coming apart our very lives
depend on it as we are now learning with
the various failures of Supply chains
and you know scarcity of various kinds
of foods our very life actually depends
on a system most of us do not understand
and that system is showing every sign of
coming apart so my sense is
we either take what we just learned from
the failures of covid
and use it to motivate us to figure out
how to repair the system well enough
that we can depend on it or we are going
to not only suffer the equivalent of
covid again in some new context maybe
having nothing to do with a pathogen
maybe it will be a different pathogen
who knows but that same collapse the
same inability of the experts to figure
out which way is up that thing is
putting us in danger and it will
continue to do so so we have to get in
the way and block that middle ground
Scramble for that Narrative of comfort
that makes people more comfortable now
and puts them in Jeopardy in the near
future yeah for sure and I think
um as you would predict from what you
just described that middle ground
scramble seems to be made up
almost entirely if not entirely of
people who are very educated
who um
have viewed themselves as heterodox on
something in the past
and who
um reveal from things that they are
saying that either they can't or have
stopped being willing to engage in
logical arguments and
um and if you are not if if you are
going to take a everything is socially
constructed view of the world
you can't also claim to be on the right
side of history and so I was thinking
about this in the context of
um for a variety of reasons some of
which I don't know but some of which is
that I was in Portland and so ran into
more people this this last week
um we we've been hearing from
um a number of people who are
appreciative of what we're doing and I
was just thinking about of the people I
know like what who are these people in
the world what are they doing and this
is by no means a complete representation
but we have farmers and gardeners
artists and Artisans and makers pilots
and teachers Healthcare professionals
and people in the military people post
on nature and actual sustainability and
conservation not the thing that's
passing for sustainability and
conservation and so many
yeah and if in so many circles now
people who don't actually like to go
outside but like to claim to be all
about nature and such
um people who don't like discomfort
we've got people who work in food co-ops
uh who understand stuff about you know
actual
actual food security who make ferments
and grow garlic and construct herbal
concoctions and get raw dairy from
people who who produce it and get it to
the people who think that they need it
or want it for for their own for their
own health
um musicians who speak truth of their
lyrics and their notes printmakers who
meld the wisdom of the past with amazing
images
there's more those every single word
that I just use there represents one or
more actual people whom we've heard from
in the last week or two and
every single one of them is doing
something real in the world with a real
manifestation in the physical world
social it's not entirely social and I
think that is going to be the you know
the predictive thing here like were you
paying attention to something that they
could not lie to you about early on or
throughout this pandemic at all so such
that at the point that what you knew to
be true because you experienced it with
your own senses and your own body at the
point that they made some claim that was
opposite you went no
not because you went into it needing to
disagree not because you went into it
needing to agree not because you were
faithful or cynical not because you're a
contrarian but because you went huh
that's not right
well now I'm going to be on a little bit
of an alert because that thing that I
was assured was true isn't true
oh there's another one
Anna oh boy and you know you quickly do
go into this space like oh wow I did not
know so many things were not true that I
was being told were true but the
assurances from the talking heads that
all you have to do is follow along and
you know I am the embodiment of science
over here and you know you just have to
do what this three-letter agency says
over here
people who actually have real physical
manifestations in the world because
they're flying planes or growing garlic
or making ferments or you know whatever
it is
we're much less likely I think
hypothesis to be fooled by this across
the board and it's the people who are
hyper-educated who don't spend time in
real physical space maybe you know maybe
build a fence like you know learn to lay
tile like something do something with
physical manifestation in the world
where you can see the results and not
negotiate your way into convincing
yourself that you're right all along
so it's interesting that you mentioned
the you know people who do something
real in the world and their ability to
spot red flags because it's interesting
I uh
Barry had Alan Lewis on her podcast
earlier I think it was last Friday she
and Michael schellenberger and Renee
duresta were on Sam Harris's podcast and
Barry says something in both cases
almost identically
which I believe is a reference you know
so in some sense in in Barry's own
podcast she tries to uninvent the IDW
and she basically imagines it as her
creation you know maybe she made her
article who created something that
didn't really exist wasn't wasn't for
real in the first place which is kind of
a nonsense uh idea but in talking about
the IDW She lays out a trajectory where
she says you know I think people
who you know got something right and
noticed that something wasn't being well
stated by the official institutions then
fell down the rabbit hole and they went
from you know the CDC was wrong on masks
or whatever her example is uh to another
example is that Bill Gates is trying to
inject you with a microchip uh in your
brain because of the great reset
this angered me to hear it because a I
think prototypical straw man it's a
prototypical straw man because it starts
out right and in fact it doesn't even
end entirely wrong is the great reset a
problem yeah I think it probably is is
Bill Gates involved yeah I don't exactly
understand why but
you know there's something there does
this have anything to do with microchips
in the brain no that was you throwing
something in there to toxify the well so
that nobody would start to try to sort
out what the relationship of these
things is so anyway
um
what I want to do most such Maneuvers
are unwitting
I'm not saying that that one was but um
take pieces that might be plausible and
add to them pieces that sound so absurd
that by tying them together you make you
you you you cause people who haven't yet
started to investigate such a thing be
like oh there's too many things to do in
the world about that one not that one
that's toxic well
I don't know if it's witting or
unwitting but this definitely feels
strategic which I do not
um I do not begrudge Barry
uh
a strategic nature obviously strategy is
important in order to get good things
accomplished but what she's
accomplishing in this case I don't
believe is legitimate and the there are
several features here that tell me
something is off
so Barry and Helen are having this
discussion and they are talking about
what the IDW is and Barry describes the
IDW
and she basically names a number of the
male participants who were in her
article
and says then there were some females as
well you are again disappeared and that
will become relevant when we get to the
part where I come in for critique I
think your disappearance has a meaning
this is not the first time we've seen it
Sam does it and Barry is now doing it
but let me let me I mean I think there's
one of three three things going on there
well let me put my hypothesis on the
table you tell me if it's in your list
the podcast that Barry does where I'm
claiming that she's involved in this
Middle Ground scramble to create an
explanation for how she and others
missed the boat on covid and uh slap
power on the wrist in a way that it will
want
um
is traffics in the uh moniker gurus
right Helen has taken up the idea of
gurus in earnest
and I am effectively portrayed as one
I think
look the fact is during covid as you and
I were doing what we did
we played different roles you know I've
always been
um more
theoretical in
my work so the roles are asymmetrical
but
there was no asymmetry in the level of
contribution in fact one of the things
that comes up in the little clip that
I'm going to play is a contribution that
you made the response to something Helen
says is something that I got from you so
my point would be
if you're gonna I don't know what we're
talking about if you're gonna level the
allegation
that um
podcast listeners are falling for gurus
right the point is well you and I don't
look like a guru because a guru doesn't
tend to look like two scientific people
having a conversation about hypotheses
predictions and tests right that's not a
guru move that's a science move yeah
right after two people to use a singular
pronoun that's just tricky right so
indeed in fact I can't even figure out
how you do it but um but the point is if
they are going to dismiss us as not
having been right because what we really
did and you know Barry's language is you
know when she says you go from spotting
that the CDC screwed up uh masks to
thinking Bill Gates is trying to inject
you with microchips if he describes it
as falling down the rabbit hole yeah it
doesn't sound good it's funny though a
lot of the heterodox thinkers who are
quite good use the metaphor rabbit hole
for themselves right the point is this
is not inherently a bad thing and in
fact a rabbit hole isn't a rabbit hole a
rabbit hole is a rabbit Warren and so in
going down a rabbit hole built into the
metaphor is the idea that there will be
blind alleys right going down the rabbit
hole is about sorting what is now but
also unexpected ways out yeah multiple
multiple ways in right so anyway
um maybe we should play the clip and
then we can talk about what it's
implicated short
um
so yeah exactly yeah we are ready
give them so much to kick against and
the more that people said do you know
these people are awful you shouldn't
listen to them you shouldn't see them
you shouldn't rather than rebutting them
either more power they got right and I
felt very strongly when I went into that
Jordan Peterson interview I this is the
one but I do remember having a
conversation with myself but I will
never say in that interview I'm never
going to say anything that you say is
offensive I'm going to say well not if I
think it's wrong and I'm going to make
the argument about why it's wrong and I
think that's the thing is that there was
the overused cudgel of a fence and
blasphemy rather than as you say you can
say to Brett Weinstein well look there's
very good evidence that the vaccines are
safe and effective and that Ivermectin
was a promising treatment at one point
but we now have a good meta-analysis
review that says sorry no it's not and
it's not a big Pharma conspiracy because
it's a generic drug that's very cheap
like you know this isn't like it would
have been you know lots of things that
were you know like basic steroids
dexamethasone for example was in exactly
the same position I ever met him was but
that one turned out to work and so
people prescribed that one like what's
your mechanism why you think this was
suppressed and that's the argument you
should be making right rather than you
must not question the wisdom of the
elders you have
to partake
okay
um
so
Helen in this clip is portraying me as
somebody who can't grok even basic
information about covet and she says you
know you can tell Brett Weinstein that
there is you know evidence that the
vaccines are safe and effective the
implication being I simply am unaware of
that evidence or worse that the evidence
exists
and that I refuse to accept it for some
reason
now the fact is there is an awful lot of
evidence there is mounting evidence that
the vaccines are unsafe it does not mean
that nobody gets away with being
injected presumably most people do but
the idea that she is simply going to
slip in there the assumption that the
evidence tells us that these things are
safe and effective is preposterous now I
will point out Barry says nothing Barry
a journalist who knows that there is
mounting evidence of the hazard of these
vaccines has an obligation
journalistically to challenge that it is
not simply true that they are safe and
effective and I believe that Barry
actually has in her Circle somebody
who's been vaccine injured so she knows
better and she had an obligation to say
so what's more she's talking about the
IDW
and there are a number of people in the
IDW or close to it who also know of
vaccine injuries so you know there's a
vaccine injured person uh in that realm
there's somebody with a spouse the fact
is this is not a realm in which a
journalist can bypass the fact that
there is evidence around us of something
more than safe and effective but then
worse she goes on
to say that um you know another thing
that you can't seem to convey to me
because apparently I'm too dumb to get
it is that Ivermectin seemed promising
but then she says but we now have a
compelling meta-analysis that tells us
that that is not the case really
I think Helen Lewis does not understand
what the state of the evidence is on
Ivermectin I think she's barely familiar
with it and that her use of the term
meta-analysis tells us that I think
she's not referring to a meta-analysis
because if she is she's either referring
to the Cochrane meta-analysis which said
Ivermectin didn't work the Cochrane
meta-analysis which is compromised by
the fact that they set inclusion
criteria for which studies would be uh
represented and then violated their own
criteria and if she's not talking about
that one she's talking about the Andy
Hill meta-analysis
the Andy Hill meta-analysis with Andy
Hill on videotape captured by Tess
Laurie admits he changed the conclusion
based on his funder's preference right
so he's certainly not talking about the
Lorry analysis meta-analysis because
that one um shows up in the opposite
direction right so a what she's done is
just if she's talking about the
meta-analyzes she's either
misrepresenting them or uh remaining
ignorant of the actual underlying
problem with these things or she doesn't
mean meta-analysis all and she's
throwing that in there to sound
technical well and I think and then
she's referring to for example the
together trial or the active six trial
where we also have evidence of fraud
where for example the dosing carries
this unexplained parameter where people
above a certain BMI have their dose
capped and when you have a disease that
afflicts people in proportion to the
degree of their obesity and you you
start under dosing people the fatter
they are of course you cause a problem
so the fact is she is representing this
as Brett Weinstein simply cannot
understand the state of the evidence
that I ever met it when in fact she
doesn't apparently understand the state
of the evidence herself well well and so
I don't I I'm not that interested in
talking about
um why I'm not present in many of these
uh many of these attempted takedowns of
you
but I said that I think that there's
three different reasons and I do think
that those three different reasons are
useful to consider across the board with
regard to this but just let's remember
that the the reason this is important is
that this cannot happen again and that
this Middle Ground scramble as you have
described it in which the institutions
that are flawed and failing are trying
to keep some of their imprimature of
seriousness and are effectively signing
on with or the other pseudo-heterodox
sort of Talking Heads or signing on with
the idea of what the institutions have
always been doing without understanding
anything about what has actually
happened and so you're just gonna get
it's like the the metaphor that I was
thinking of is like it's it's like
rearranging deck chairs on the analysis
except for rearranging intellectuals
like it's just like you've got you're
gonna replace some of the old Talking
Heads with some new Talking Heads and
they seemed heterodox at some point but
it turns out they're not courageous
these are not the courageous people
they're just following along like
everyone else looking for power and no
not everything is about power but these
moves are so
um you know why why don't I show up when
Sam Harris talks and Scott Adams and you
know and Helen Lewis and Barry Weiss and
such I think it's one of three reasons
and it's some combination often
one because people aren't actually
paying attention they've never heard you
and me talk they've they never heard you
talk
um they haven't actually engaged the
material they've gotten their
information from someone else and that I
suspect not knowing very much at all
about the situation is what for instance
Helen has done she has she's never heard
anything here and you know but it's also
true that you know you went on with
Robert Malone and Steve Kersh you went
out with Pierre Corey like you do the
the guest hosting and so you know you're
more out there you're easier for the
people who want to hate on you know what
it is that we're doing and what you're
doing to grab you and to take it and so
I think one of the big reasons is
um it's a reveal of actually I never
actually listened to or read anything
that here they said and so I'm gonna
just focus there that's one
second reason is that in some cases
um not this particular these these two
women presumably although I don't know
is that it's actual cryptic misogyny and
that they're accustomed to not paying
attention to women being influential in
a space
um that sounds you know that sounds like
things that they can't understand and
therefore probably this is not a thing
that women would do uh well so that's
obnoxious and
terrible if it's true and yeah but I do
think that that is um that is part of
the reason sometimes and the third
reason
uh I think that this happens and I do
think that this is part of what's going
on with the um podcast you're talking
about now is that it's strategic and
it's more difficult to take down the two
of us together because as you say uh we
don't look like a guru right we look
like two people with scientific
backgrounds and yes also credentials but
that's not the thing that matters here
we have decades both individually and
even more decades between us thinking
carefully through scientific
patterns and processes making
observations in the world figuring out
what hypotheses might explain them how
to test between how to discriminate
between those hypotheses and how to move
forward that is what we do
professionally both of us and yes I'm
more of an empiricist back when we were
actually practicing scientists in the
way that most people think of when they
think of it and you were more of a
theorist but you know I do Theory you do
empiricism like we we both do both
things and it's just far easier to have
it be especially in this era this like
this even the people who claim to be the
most anti-work like oh let's go after
the dude he's you know it's it's just
it's this guy who's just off off the
cuff he's just not making any sense you
just can't talk to him you can't talk to
him about Ivermectin really like I'm I'm
guessing that this is what you were
talking about when you said that one of
the things that they talk about is
something that I brought I haven't
gotten there yet okay well like I
remember
I remember having gotten up one early
one Saturday back
almost two years ago probably maybe two
years ago and we were still living in
Portland and I don't remember how I went
there but I went down that rabbit Warren
have Ivermectin and emergency use
authorizations and you came downstairs
and I looked at you my jaw dropped was
like
I think I have stumbled upon the most
egregious example yet of anything in the
pandemic to date that that I or we have
talked about and it was Ivermectin so
that's the piece yeah um it is
specifically the emergency use
authorization because the last thing
that Helen says in the clip that we
played is that it doesn't even make
sense that there would be uh some sort
of collusion to exclude Ivermectin as a
treatment for covid because it's a
generic drug and it's cheap okay Alan
that's a non-sequitur right the reason
that people imagine that Ivermectin was
blocked was because it was a direct
competitor to these vaccines which were
emergency use authorized and emergency
use authorization requires that they're
not be a viable treatment in order to be
granted yeah they're being a direct
component yeah likes people have not
heard that they're being a direct
competitor to the vaccine to to the
vaccines to uh prevent coven precludes
the eua and therefore would have
precluded uh the vaccines going on the
market when they did right and then she
says that um this her point is proven
because uh she names a
um
steroid that is
something uh I'm
going to skip it for the second but the
point is the fact that some other
generic drug is being used and yes it is
used for pulmonary uh compromise that
comes along with covid is it
dextromethorphan no no no no no
um anyway the fact that she uses the
fact that she uses this example is uh
evidence that she doesn't understand
what's going on because the point is
Ivermectin has two values it does treat
people with covid effectively assuming
you treat them early with a sufficient
dose
this has been demonstrated many times
and we can talk about why you think the
evidence says that it doesn't but that
evidence is not persuasive but the other
thing it does is it is a preventative of
Contracting covet and so the point is
these you're comparing uh apples to
spaceships that they're not comparable
and
um
you know
I'm now thrown by Zach who says that we
didn't play as much of the clip as our
as I uh thought that we played but
nonetheless there's like four or five
sentences involved in her critique and
there's three or four critical errors in
what she says now my point is going to
be if he's not actually trying to make
an analytical point she's trying to
sound like she's making an analytical
point the actual payload of this entire
exploration
is the word guru
the idea is
this is not going to compel anybody who
actually pays attention to the podcast
what this is going to do is prevent
other people from paying attention
that's its purpose is to stigmatize us
to make us sound like and and this is a
move that we see repeatedly now the idea
is if that thing persuades you that's
because you're a sucker and so the point
is anybody who hears us and thinks oh
well that's not what I thought it was
that actually sounds kind of compelling
that sounds like a scientific discussion
that sounds like a discussion I'd like
to pay attention to ah you're a sucker
you're falling for a guru it's you know
something is fitting a religion-shaped
hole in your persona and that's why
you're responding to it so this is
designed it's like you know
it's like skunk stink it's supposed to
make it difficult for people to get
anywhere near this discussion because
really the point is another discussion
has to take place and it's not up to the
challenge
yeah well I will I will repeat that um I
mean also not on my list of people we've
been hearing from who are um grateful
for the conversations in which we um try
to logic through evidence out loud in
front of the camera uh our uh many
Tradesmen right we got roofers and and
you know all all sorts of people who are
again doing physical things in the world
uh
I would hope
that anyone who is so convinced that
what uh we're doing is based on a simple
rubric of contrarianism
or
um falling prey to some kind of
something something something
uh I I propose first that you know
that's you're recognizing a part of your
own brain and that part is not
necessarily Universal
and that if you get yourself in the
habit of doing something physical in the
world
and seeing the manifestations of it then
you will be more able in the future to
distinguish between arguments that are
careful and logical and arguments which
are entirely based in Social conclusions
and I think most of what we're hearing
um most of what you're talking about
here are arguments based entirely in the
social sphere with sort of nodding
passing
referral to uh sciency things but this
is coming from people who aren't
actually engaging any of the evidence
yeah
um that's quite right
I would say that they've there are
multiple ways that they are attempting
to dismiss the conversation that now
needs to take place and people should be
um aware of all of them right you've
mentioned contrarianism right to the
extent that the system got really
essentially everything wrong about covid
from its origin to the best mechanism
for treating it to the safety of the
vaccines all of these things the utility
of vitamin D all of these things that
got wrong and so if the system is in the
practice of getting everything wrong yes
a contrarian could get there without
understanding anything but that doesn't
make people who understood contrarians
by Nature yeah no and I and I think we
talked about this last week but I wrote
I wrote a piece in my subset last year
that
I have been just been sending to people
when they you know like oh you're just a
contrarian like no that is the opposite
of science it is the opposite of science
is the opposite of science so is Faith
both of those things simply having an
idea in advance of I will or I will I
will accept or I will reject whatever
the authority says that's not scientific
um in addition
I also uh hear especially from uh from
various quadrants including
um
oh boy
damn
I've forgotten
um
the
thing that Barry says in this podcast is
that and actually Helen picks up on this
and runs with it the idea is that all of
this is explainable by audience capture
right a term that held incorrectly
attributes to Eric and then missed
defines Right audience capture would be
the idea that you simply start saying
the things that the audience wants to
hear because it's lucrative right and I
want to point out that yes that's a very
sophisticated sounding uh rationale for
dismissing a correct line of logic but
what is really obvious and should be
obvious to anybody who pays attention to
this podcast is that we are very
frequently
arriving at a position for which there
is exactly no audience right like for
example
um global warming is real it's dangerous
but the models are crap and the fields
that study this are going to be
compromised by the same perverse
incentives that compromise covid policy
the vaccines are obviously a hazard
so is covet right the obvious thing if
you were going to follow some uh path to
some audience that wanted to hear
something is to follow it to some
audience that actually exists like
covet's not serious and the vaccines are
dangerous
um right but the point is time and time
again I remember being asked by a
conservative friend
maybe a year into the pandemic
why is it that you're skeptical of
vaccines and yet you think covet is a
real problem
and I mean that was really the phrasing
and I'm not going to say who it was and
I thought what what do those two things
have to do with one another those are
two different that those are those are
really unrelated and if you are coming
to your conclusions because of who your
team has voted for yeah you're not doing
science
so you know let's put it this way you
can just simply look at the various ways
that um
and I don't I wish this weren't personal
I wish we were talking about somebody
else's podcast because it would be a lot
easier to do this but you can't get to
where we are by contrarianism by
reflexive contrarianism because the
point is the place that we have arrived
is not otherwise on the map right
you can't get there through luck because
the track record is too many uh things
that were unlikely but turned out
um to be true and you can't get there by
uh falling down a rabbit hole either
because the point is the pattern would
Peter out
so none of these things
um make sense it's not a coin flip it's
a scientific process it is uh it
shouldn't be true that it is possible to
do this on a podcast and
um you know come up with a superior
model to whatever the CDC is playing
with but it is apparently possible and
that really is the discussion we should
be having it has nothing to do with
gurus
and
um you know it's really uh
it's quite disgusting for people who
have not gotten coveted right to be
challenging those who have gotten it
right over time through a process which
we have done in public so that other
people will not pay attention right that
is just it's an unacceptable thing to do
and frankly the amount of hutzpah
involved in doing such a thing is pretty
remarkable I must say I'm a bit
horrified to be hearing this from both
Sam uh and Barry both of them know
better and
um I really I hope they find their way
back to sanity
okay we're gonna um
talk a little bit about dogs next time
we promised promise this time but uh I
think maybe it's time for us to take our
break for the week yep and come back
with a Q and A shortly uh for those of
you who don't do the Q a we'll be back
again same time next week we will not be
doing a q a next week but we will be
back with our regular live stream you
can ask questions for the Q a at
darkhorsesmissions.com
uh consider joining our patreons reading
her together is Guide to the 21st
century and until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
foreign